frédéric tu ne le crois pas en dieu
je pense que
dieu est peut-être
mais en tout cas certainement sous
aucune des formes que l'on nous a
enseigné
et et moi j'ai samou
finalement ça
c'est affreux à dire mais ça m'intéresse
pas
est ce que ton fils mathieu est baptisée
wii il est baptisé parce que
j'attache beaucoup d'importance ah
au fait qu'un enfant
eux
soit comme les autres et ça fait partie
de notre culture de notre
de notre vie et
après il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut donc il ya des gens qui tiennent le
raisonnement inverse moi j'ai préféré
celui-là
l'accusé maintenant il a 20 ans 21 on
n'a jamais su si c'était ton ombre et
fils ou ton fils adoptif c'est tout à
fait mon vrai fils c'était une
c'est à dire que c'est il a vécu avec
moi d'une manière un peu compliqué
en cause du désordre
de la jeunesse qui était ma jeunesse en
l'occurrence mais c'est mon vrai fils et
puis même s'il est témoin en fils
adoptif il serait aussi membre et fils
toute façon je trouve terrible cette
différence la seule chose qui compte
c'est la manière dont les gens
s'occupent des autres mais en tout cas
c'est mon vrai fils parce que tu vois
toujours sa mère
[Musique]
non parce que
la drogue a tué beaucoup de gens
qui l'a élevé
je les ai élevés mais pas très bien
c'est à dire que je ne me suis pas
assez bien occupé que j'étais sans doute
un peu tyrannique avec lui je les péchés
de respirer quoi
et
et voilà il faudrait lui demander à lui
si tu devais mourir là quelle serait la
seule chose que tu voudrais lui dire à
ce moment là
je t'aime
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu